we've now had three days of debate on
the withdrawal agreement setting out the
terms of our departure from the EU and
the political declarations setting out
our future relationship after we have
left
I've listened very carefully to what has
been said in this chamber and out of it
[Applause]
- what has been said in this chamber and
out of it by members from all sides from
listening to those views it is clear
that while there is broad support for
many of the key aspects of the deal on
one issue on one issue the Northern
Ireland backstop there remains
widespread and deep concern as a result
if we went ahead and held the vote
tomorrow the deal would be rejected by a
significant margin we will therefore
defer the vote scheduled for tomorrow
and not proceed to divide the house at
this time I set out in my speech opening
the debate last week the reasons why the
back stop is a necessary guarantee to
the people of Northern Ireland and why
whatever future relationship you want
there is no deal available that does not
include the backstop behind all those
arguments are some inescapable facts the
fact that Northern Ireland shares a land
border with another sovereign state the
fact the fact that the hard-won peace
the fact that the hard-won peace that
has been built in Northern Ireland over
the last two decades has been built
around a seamless border and the fact
that brexit will create a wholly new
situation on the 30th of March the
Northern Ireland Ireland border will for
the first time become the external
frontier of the European Union's single
market and customs union
the challenge the challenge this poses
must be met not with rhetoric but with
real and workable solutions businesses
operate across that border people live
their lives crossing and recrossing it
every day I've been there and spoken to
some of those people they do not want
their everyday lives to change as a
result of the decision we have taken
they do not want a return to our hard
border and if this house cares about
preserving our union it must listen to
those people because our union will only
end or with their consent we had hoped
that the changes we've secured to the
backstop would reassure members that we
could never be trapped in it
indefinitely I hope the house will
forgive me if I take a moment to remind
it of those changes the customs element
of the backstop is now uk-wide it no
longer splits our country into two
customs territories this also means that
the backstop is now an uncomfortable
arrangement for the EU so they won't
want it to come into usour persist for
long if it does both sides are now
legally committed to using best
endeavours to have our new relationship
in place before the end of the
implementation period ensuring the
backstop is never used if our new
relationship isn't ready we can now
choose to extend the implementation
period further reducing the likelihood
of the backstop coming into use if the
backstop ever does come into use we now
don't have to get the new relationship
in place to get out of it alternative
arrangements that make use of technology
could be put in place instead the treaty
the treaty is now clear that the
backstop can only ever be temporary and
there is now a termination course
but I but I am clear what I from what I
have heard in this place and for my own
conversations that these elements do not
offer a sufficient number of colleagues
the reassurance that they need I spoke
to a number of EU leaders over the
weekend and in advance of the European
Council I will go to see my counterparts
in other member states and the
leadership of the council and the
Commission I will discuss with them the
clear concerns that this house has
expressed we are also looking closely at
new ways of empowering the House of
Commons to ensure that any provision for
a backstop has democratic legitimacy and
to enable the House to place its own
obligations on the government to enable
a house to place its own obligations on
the government to ensure that the
backstop cannot be in place indefinitely
mr. speaker having spent the best part
of two years poring over the detail of
brexit listening to the public's
ambitions and yes their fears to and
testing the limits of what the other
side is prepared to accept I mean
absolutely no doubt that this deal is
the right one it honors the result of
the referendum
the remainder of the statement must be
heard and I invite the house to hear it
with courtesy and for the avoidance of
doubt and also the benefit of those
attending to our proceedings who are not
members of house I emphasize that as per
usual I will call everyone who wants to
question the Prime Minister but
meanwhile please hear the Prime Minister
it honors the result of the referendum
it protects jobs security and our union
but it also represents the very best
deal that is actually negotiable with
the EU
I believe in it as do many members of
this house and I still believe there is
a majority to be won in this house in
support of it if I can secure additional
reassurance on the question of the
backstop and that is what my focus will
be in the days ahead
but mr. speaker if you take a step back
it is clear that this house faces a much
more fundamental question does this
house want to deliver
grexit
[Applause]
and clear a clear message from the SNP
but if the house does does it want to do
so through reaching an agreement with
the EU if the answer is yes and I
believe that is the answer of the
majority of this house then we all have
to ask ourselves whether we're prepared
to make a compromise because there will
be no enduring and successful brexit
without some compromise on both sides of
the debate
many of the most controversial aspects
of this deal including the backstop are
simply inescapable facts of having a
negotiated brexit those members who
continue to disagree need to shoulder
the responsibility of advocating an
alternative solution that can be
delivered and do so and do so without
docking its implications so if you want
a second referendum to overturn the
result of the first be honest that this
risks dividing the country again
[Applause]
be honest that this risks dividing the
country again when it's a house we
should be striving to bring it back
together
if you if you want to remain part of the
single market in the customs union be
open that this would require free
movement rule taking across the economy
and ongoing financial contributions none
of which are in my view compatible with
the result of the referendum
if you if you want to leave without a
deal be upfront that in the short term
this would cause significant economic
damage to parts of our country who can
least afford to bear the burden I do not
believe that any of those courses of
action command a majority in this house
but notwithstanding that fact for as
long as we fail to agree a deal the risk
of an accidental No Deal increases so
the government so the government will
step up its work in preparation for that
potential outcome and the cabinet will
hold further discussions on it this week
from a fast majority of us mr. speaker
except the result of the referendum and
want to leave with a deal we have a
responsibility to discharge if we will
the ends we must also will the means and
I know that members across the house
appreciate how important that
responsibility is and I'm very grateful
to all members on this side of the house
and a few on the other side to whose
backs this deal and spoken up for it
many many others many others I know have
been wrestling with their consciences
particularly over the question of the
backstop seized of the need to face up
to the challenge posed by the Irish
border but genuinely concerned about the
consequences I have listened I have
heard those concerns and I will now do
everything I possibly can to secure
further assurances if I may conclude mr.
speaker on a personal note on the
morning after the referendum two and a
half years ago I knew that we had
witnessed a defining moment for our
democracy places that didn't get a lot
of attention at elections and which did
not get much coverage on the news were
making their voices heard and saying
that they wanted things to change
I knew in that moment that Parliament
had to deliver for them but of course
that doesn't just mean delivering brexit
it means working across all areas
building a stronger economy improving
public services
tackling tackling tackling social
injustice --is to make this a country
that truly works for everyone
the Prime Minister must be heard the
Prime Minister tackling social injustice
--is to make this a country that truly
works for everyone a country where
nowhere and nobody is left behind and
these matters are too important to be
afterthoughts in our politics they
deserve to be at the centre of our
thinking but that can only happen if we
get brexit done and get it done right
and even though I voted remain from the
moment I took up the responsibility of
being Prime Minister of this great
country I've known that my duty is to
honor the result of that vote and I've
been just as determined to protect the
jobs that put food on the tables of
working families and the security
partnerships and the security
partnerships that keep each one of us
safe and that's what this deal does it
gives us control of our borders our
money and our laws
it protects job security and our union
it is the right deal for Britain I am
determined to do all I can to ship
secure the reassurances this house
requires to get this deal over the line
and deliver for the British people and I
commend this statement to the house